on this episode we talk musically with
musically celebs
you ask
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 198 on
the ask Gary B show we've been
completely out of rhythm with the show
India
I've been ridiculously busy I haven't
even really snapped all that much in the
last 48 hours it's been intense and the
other thing with the show and these 190s
seems like every episode now has guests
I have more for you on an episode I am
super excited about much like I put out
a video yesterday about me talking about
snapchat in 2014 I have a funny feeling
that this video will be showing up in my
social media in about 18 to 24 months as
we get to talk about a platform there's
really caught my attention over the last
six to nine months six months really
called musically the two lovely ladies
that are here with me are people this
section really fun an episode unlike
what I could have done early on with
snapchat and brought people in that
we're doing extremely well on snapchat I
kind of did what I normally did over the
last decade with Twitter and YouTube and
Facebook I learned I watched this is the
first time that I'm bringing people on
the show in an environment where because
of my busy schedule because of my own
relationship with music I'll get into
that in a second these two young ladies
are far much further along in their
execution and understanding of musically
than I am which is something I don't
usually like to do with myself
especially in a public environment so
I'm excited because I think you're going
to bring a lot of value not only to the
audience but to me myself and I like
being selfish a little better day so why
don't you before we get into this show
tell the vaynernation who you guys are
my name is Arielle Martin but I've also
known as baby Arielle my name is Arianna
trills but I'm also known as Dale Avari
and basically we're really wait did you
guys have rehearsed that that was very
impressed yeah
right make sense that's why you guys are
winning so it's a lip-syncing app and
you could do any kind of lip-syncing
videos you want to hip up to pop to
comedy and you get to show your
personality and be creative with it real
quick on the lip-syncing part I've seen
I've been looking at it enough to know
some people lip-sync but there's
obviously other people things people can
be doing interacting acting through the
music or different things that makes
your original music are you both
lip sinkers yes we do we don't know each
other yes really well yes you guys look
at the same town today it's way off
amazing away free shy no one on this
platform yes
before you get into what you view things
let's actually take it all the way back
a couple things how old are you guys 15
next
yes is that when did you guys first
become aware of musically
oh I started actually I found it through
Instagram okay this girl posted a video
like using it I asked her what app is
that because it looks really like fast
motion and cool so I asked her what
Apple was and I she told me musically
and I from then I showed my friends it
happened tell us where and when this bad
happen yeah happen Nick what my over
shut up
may 18th me that's the day I showed her
pretty sure and I was on it like May 17
May 17 3 and 3/4 okay so so okay fine
you discover it in May yes um when did
the up come out in the u.s. do you know
I think two years that goes when it
started is very basic got it right it
pivoted a little bit along the way what
we'll have a more in-depth I think any I
think what we'll use yeah and I think I
think you know what I think we've waited
longer than we even had to on our kind
of complete guide to snapchat I think we
might as well take our first step at at
a complete guide to musically so we'll
do that okay so it's May right at that
point had you when you heard about when
she told you about that was the first
time you'd heard about it yeah and
nobody else at this point in your school
and 15 woody guys freshman thanks Mia
nobody nobody was talking about it
just yet right now well that was yeah
down in 8,000 eighth grade he's great
guy right last year got it at that time
what happened over the summer did it
completely explode this summer that's
yeah at that time we were just otter
like posting random videos to our
friends yeah so during the summer
that's when we started to make more i
got featured I think most most positive
it was the weekend of July 4th but you
were like a month before kind of yeah
cuz I was there we got featured uh-huh
oh my god so a piece of your content got
featured by the app yeah basically what
happened overnight how many followers
did you go from I remember them that
week I like that video got featured and
I got like 2,000 to 5,000 that week and
I just kept going and I was kind of
freaking out
now do you at this point how many
followers do you have now now I have 7.4
million
I have 3.7 million yeah and so are you
at a place now where when you go out of
mourning kids go now like the mall or
out and out yeah people are rolling up
on you yeah yeah are you taking a lot of
selfies yes and you love that I love it
yeah yeah me too yeah companies you I
assume with those kind of numbers and so
now what what's been going on so good
through summer picks up momentum like
did you like couldn't wait to the first
day of school because you were curious
I'm like whatever we're nervous really I
was scared
everyone's like us because we're getting
so much like you weren't about haters
yeah yeah I mean like I got India hater
I'm kidding come on because it was like
our first year in high school so it was
a bunch of new people and we were some
what happened
I was it was fun right maybe the first
week one or two were like oh no she goes
to our school yeah I'm the first station
a really good we were worried about like
if people saw that we're growing so much
they we want to be our friends now and
didn't want to be our friends before
d-roc has that problem now everybody
want to be his friend and he's
struggling with balancing if they
actually want to be his friend
be with you rock I'll talk to me about I
know we're gonna focus more musically
but I want to bounce out for a second
within social prior to that what apps
were you using January to May of last of
this year or last year Instagram or
snapchat yeah and so where are you you
become a musically celebrity has that
crossed over into your Instagram and
snap yes yes yes and and then as I don't
know if you're able to answer this
because I could make sense to me I have
my notoriety on my platforms but then I
can act like my normal self in other
places are you in a place right now
since this is all so new that it's kind
of hard for you not to be the like are
you able to be your own person in those
other apps
yeah understandable in snapchat snapchat
you could take them around sometimes you
will take them around all day like what
we do or just basically be yourself and
show who we really are not just behind
the camera but notice what you just said
to them that's still fanbase how about
to your inner slick in your in your life
like you're seven to nine core friends
or acquaintances yeah thanks I do what
are you using or using are you
snapchatting exactly to them yeah yeah
exactly like about using Twitter yes I
do want to tweet are you using right
looks about to me prior to many we're
using Twitter to follow celebrities yes
some yeah yeah but winner was number
three behind Instagram and snapchat for
you yeah yes right cuz I even know what
have you ever heard of Facebook yes good
for on Facebook whereas like like a good
and I gotta be short of thinking about
YouTube yeah we do weekly videos got it
now now what's happening where what is
it right now a book it's a freshman
you're starting to ramp up right yes
right so what's happening with the
friends around you like where is
musically now sitting with the 15 year
olds and mobile actually do younger
siblings I have a little brother Alice
he's 12 and what is he using he is
everything
what's his order in your opinion like
what's his favorite app he loves
musically
of course his sister's a [ __ ] star
sorry Kay Curson
okay I'm sure you love the one sagami-ya
most next he's a very good snapchatter
like he's you respect his skin I've it
yes I didn't know you could be very now
in art his twelve-year-old friends also
using those two apps yes okay
hell yeah and so what's happening in
high school in high school freshman
class musically in snapchatter 1 & 2 or
Instagram like give me the ratings this
is complete data collection for me yeah
this is a personal episode I don't think
musically as past snapchat right so it's
snapchat yeah where's musically an
Instagram sitting in your opinion your
class oh well not none of my friends use
Instagram like that no more oh they
usually just basically use snapchat and
Twitter
they don't use Instagram snapchat
Twitter yeah
Twitter's getting up there a lot of
people are getting up there because
you're able to like I guess they can
talk Twitter stock they can talk to each
other like IU Witter you see a lot of
funny videos and it's just like so many
funny things happen on Twitter
never mind like I love Twitter morning
show how are you guys - look what is
your family I mean like let's show all
over this your family's around here you
know you they are like what do they
think about like what's your dad I
wouldn't wanna be my mom was just like
at first she's like oh that's really
good and I like the first time I got
notice she was like this is real like
you're really getting noticed
same with my dad like my dad has been
this was recently about month ago we
went to Key West and I got notice it was
like you're so right like this is going
to wearing and now everywhere we go Dino
her Dino her this is my daughter yeah I
really the first month when I start like
I started to like really like blow up we
were all kinda like what's going on they
were like okay get the domain name for
baby Arielle calm get a youtube channel
right now oh yeah Lucinda my god
nice work and my mom also I remember he
was like he he's the first week he's
like get the domain name we're again
doing baby Arianna common me my mom will
do him like are you are you serious I'll
say come on
and now when I was right cause it was
very right I never liked big guy Jose
gotcha
so now what actually looks like this
route what would you like to see what do
you think musically is doing well that
you like better than the other platforms
what I like about it is that it's not
you're not just like you don't just have
to do lip synching you don't just have
to do comedy you can really make
whatever kind of video that you want you
can add someone else's voice and you can
lip-sync to their comedy voice you can
lip-sync to whatever yeah you can also
like there's a segment where you can
import videos from your phone and add
music into it so let's say you want to
put a statue anything like Oh add me on
snapchat or then you visited somewhere
really nice and you'll put it in and add
some music
you could add like a picture feel like
the music helps you create content in a
world where other platforms yes you can
just bring boys yeah like a lot of
people say like when they watch our
videos on musically it's kind of like
telling a story with the lyrics like
yeah France it's like interpreting yeah
and you're way not directly what the
lyrics are saying with your version
exactly you could do like expression so
it just makes it all look like a real
music video have you discovered music
that you would have never known about
yes without me yes that has changed the
things you like and exactly yeah I mean
I have like how many musically videos
450 ish and like most of them I got like
through other people's it's cool like
like you're exploring my different
styles of music that I had never thought
I would listen to just on a regular
basis and learned a lot of words to the
song and everyone's like you know the
words and I'm like on the random like oh
yeah I know that for musically I did
that but sometimes I got only know 15
seconds of me - I only know the hook
no real quick are you guys just like you
can't wait for summer vacation to start
yeah but then you don't spend those
extra seven hours in class now you can
produce a lot more yes make sure and so
what about from a business standpoint
like have you guys like this is
obviously all new territory there's a
lot of tension on you guys have you had
brands reach out or do you think you
like what do you how are you thinking
about your business worlds yeah well
recently I just launched my nail polish
this is the best and Arielle you have
lips never lipstick lied yeah we have
websites with mercs like we kind of do
the same thing like she has bracelet I
have bracelet shirts I could have had
and how's it going well yeah yes you're
talking the RISM business shows that's
exactly where we get to talk about it
that's great guys well I'm super happy
for you thank you all right
I think we should do a question yeah
let's do it Casey asks how many times
does it take you to make a musically
well Casey oh it depends on the song
that we're working on or the type of
musically that we're working on certain
songs might take us an hour yeah I like
saying we're perfections like if it
doesn't look right that I did it
are you guys producing a lot of content
together like you're going region yeah I
should be like alright let's get to work
yes and that's cool cuz since we live
like a minute away from each other
what do you walk you can we we could
we'd like to be like what do you do
drive nice but you don't drive yet no no
no that's your parents who drive one
more I think it's like the thing is like
we do like a banana walking because we
do like events and stuff together so
like our moms will talk about like
something that we're going to do like
like a god Oh meaning great we did one a
month like kind of a month ago right
before spring break you showing up to
the mean Greeks like what what
percentage are girls of your age it's
kind of like anyways just I'm like six I
should get young is total chicks to like
12 13 or 17 yes 17 the oldest is
probably 17 17
that's longer honest but this owner came
she was 12 and her older sister was like
22 but she's like my sister showed me
her and I really like you all yeah I
wasn't had a friend she's like my Gina
is like she's worked with this girl for
like about three months or so and she
was like oh my cousin saw musically pop
up on her phone she's like yeah
musically it she's like yeah and I love
those two girls she's like Ari's my
cousin she's like no way she's like
you're like 26 it's like I know more you
dude they're like
yeah that American Idol like people love
that you know like just don't you think
26 is old right yeah yeah like that
meager stuff like gonna happen man okay
so what about this how many boys show up
to these things
oh maybe like one or two or three so
it's a dominant dominant yeah we
definitely have boys yeah and is that
good never really I mean put it there
like they're cute yeah well I feel like
we're young for 15 year old melon we
never really met most of our boy like
supporter you know what no I there's
like there was a command grade that like
five to eight came yeah well yeah which
is like it's cool like this course again
they're like so nervous doing hi you
guys are famous chicks to this stuff
alright yeah Luka asks what makes
musically great what's the future of it
I would I like most I think like it
really like when I go on it allows me to
be creative
cuz I might want to do a comedy want to
be funny that day or I want to make a
lip-sync and also depending on the star
that I want to do if it's a really sad
song like will you make sad content when
you're actually sad yes add content when
you're like you know I've been doing a
lot of funny I've been doing a lot of
there so yeah well cuz yen as majority
check exactly cuz I'm I just I want to
think of it as like oh whatever I want
to do like let's just do it
but if I did 10 comedies the other day I
can't do anymore honey pieces of content
will you do in a day I try it's a good
day like yeah I'm ready first don't use
Glee I'll do like three or four you're
just kind of like I'm coming home tired
I'll be like one or two huh yes but if
it's saying yeah what any what is it
you'll do the first day of summer a bike
yeah just sometimes I'll be like came on
leave me alone I'm doing musically I'll
be in the flag two hours and that that's
an acceptable thing right like moms are
go
exactly okay she walks in like mom like
no guitars and it's like if I get in
trouble I'm like hi can't take my phone
away because I can't stop posting music
please cuz then they're gonna be like
we're sorry your words are yellow
there's days like what about the
comments so obviously comments you know
especially the young age is that you're
at right
like how down do you get when the
comments are mean alert how do you deal
with positive versus negative comments
at the beginning when I first started
yeah there's a lot of comments and it
was like me but then like I have such I
haven't really set like high esteem
socially I don't care like not really I
don't even look at my comics at all I
don't know nothing because because you
don't want to get down yeah on the stuff
that's negative I actually started an
anti-bullying movement yep because at
first I got a lot of comments of the
same thing that just first stupid day
like oh you're a little--you're what are
you doing little bit and like instead I
was like pushing it to the side because
that's what most people I saw do they
just ignore it
I like tweeted about it and I was like
oh you know this isn't right because if
I'm getting it then who knows like there
were you love you a girl that gets it of
course and for many people watching your
little girl so I'm excited yeah so real
quick have you thought about engaging
the comments like do you say thanks for
people giving you love and picture on
Instagram it's really hard to see
because there's so much like I have 1.1
million you have 1.9 it's hard to see
but Twitter is mainly where I noticed a
lot of people and I'll favor all the
tweets that I tweet on Instagram like
it's yeah like she said it's hard to do
one by one but there's days where I'll
post a picture of me hugging a supporter
and say like thank you to everybody and
I mean about I'm unique and musically
huh how do you think about the community
I think it's positive they're just some
kids that are cruel and they'll just go
on like to our pages comments route they
have you thought about engaging with
them or incorporating them into your
pond yeah yeah yeah I actually thank you
that I talked about that was my family
the other day I wanted to start doing
like once a week maybe a duet
competition and how do you guys think
about collaborations obviously you guys
- man I had one doing I think about
collabing with each other that was easy
have you done a lot of collabos thought
yes that a lot I've done one with I got
a three or four yeah three getting
passed by a lot of people that are
trying to build up their music we used
to do a collaboration not really if I
collab with someone they'll probably be
like my cousin cuz she's also musically
and she loves it so but I usually if I
like we're going to actually in a vet
Nick's in like a week or so like ten
days called playlist live yep and all of
our friends that were in a group chair
what they're going to be there so they
all want to collab and we're very
excited mm-hmm
do you rock hmm let's get Odin laughs um
okay uh idiot
Paul asks well snapchat ever allow us to
sort our friends into groups if not why
oh I really hope they add like a friends
list or maybe change that aspect up a
little bit yeah because sometimes I want
to set it to a person and then I'll
accidentally click a wrong name send it
to the wrong person I'm like oh sorry so
maybe they should be able to like let
you choose frame groups that like let's
say you I mean just to be round 10 to
Arielle this so so maybe I should have
like a friend list like this group I
want to see to this group you know my
point of view on a Ian Cruz up you know
I think I think what snapchat and
musically have done really well as the
next-generation platforms that have
attention is they've not followed the
historic patterns of the other platforms
which i think has brought a lot of
relevance to this demo so I think
they'll be very calculated I mean I
think Evans clearly shown the last four
years that he has no interest in paying
attention to what everybody else wants
him to do with the product and I think
he'll be pretty calculated with Maree
goes with it I think I think even if the
demo is pent up and asking for it
they're not going to be so quick to add
that feature
I think they clearly want to be the
number one messaging app in the world
that's why they put so much into this
latest update speaking of which how do
you like the latest update in the
snapchat like being able to go out I
don't like that when you too many things
I don't know I like I like the filters
and everything I just don't like the
story part where when you're doing
watching someone's story and
automatically yeah the next one I don't
like that it's too much effort for you
to just go up and get out of it well
sometimes like it just comes your
you're sponsored babies playing I'm
polishes to men and you don't want to do
it sometimes like when if you don't if
you get onto and I just click it out
it's still there showing that's a recent
update and that bothers me I like to
clear it out understood and for you yeah
what are you sure what about the chat
one-on-one chat bunch of apologize work
Oh Rebecca that's a guy like do you I
know I did that for everybody to leave a
comment on it my people love to leave
comments that I interrupt purpose
because I love the hate um so we're not
sure what have you on the chat aspect
the chat aspect I think it's cool I
haven't really gotten a chance to really
delve into it yeah just making too many
music please
so one last thing I definitely want to
know one more time in the collective
high school you're in where what if you
had have one net score fresh for the
seniors the ranks just your opinions ah
the number one app is snapchat right now
no Twitter for my school it's Twitter
really yes
Twitter and where's the number one like
if use the number one across all users
of all four grades the amount of people
that are on it and who enters in you yet
Twitter because everyone's like this
sense unbelievable play Twitter into a
video this said I'm not wow what's your
Twitter doesn't your Twitter and next is
probably snapchat yeah
I'm definitely and then people really
like I mean they don't like musically
they think it's cool that we're like we
do it yes but they don't really go on it
like they've made some here and Angela
oh yeah and then they'll come up to me
like really consuming because I
understood making versus consuming is a
whole nother thing I mean I do think the
barrier of making me a very good
musically is harder I do think one of
them is snapchat has going for it is you
can be like you know like there's
clearly a creative level in musically
similar to YouTube's similar to other
platforms similar by the way of early
Instagram and it's actually where I
think musically goes I think musically
now has a threshold of creative that I'm
very curious does it go the route of you
YouTube and continues to be important
and always important or does it go the
route of what Instagram did because
early Instagram you know
like it was really photography yes like
that was the early crew and then it Main
Street down watching this main stream
out from afar for me in your demo and
younger especially as you start seeing
these 7 8 9 10 11 12 year olds it'll be
interesting to see if people are willing
to not make perfect me are you going to
be in a place in 24 months where you'll
be thinking differently the level of
them musically that you need to make
versus the way you're thinking about it
today show how you make one yeah I just
don't like quick one-minute demo how you
make one so it's pretty cool okay good
any song in particular no your favorite
okay because this one you get to this
morning blessings you do it together
oh yeah a lot of me myself and I yeah oh
yeah basically you just choose your
phone I mean choose you can are you keys
on once you get up with them will up
explain wait go back so you can see the
music part oh so you're gonna there's
different um settings it's epic slow
normal fast and lapse epic is fast right
epic see I'll show you I think click on
it yeah so slow is gonna be in fact and
normal normal and then fast is what we
use and it's in slow motion
and it just combines it to being fast it
looks cool and then there's a timer that
they just added and now you can switch
the camera and also you can cut the
music to where you want to put and they
provide you at 30 seconds if it's on
because they have songs on there but you
can also get it from your own library
and you can choose from the whole song
and have you been happy with the peach
the speed in which the feature update
yeah been coming yes yes yes very happy
all right good so you're a summary corn
no together be fun together
that's love in the other side yeah I got
that by a muscle all right let's uh I'm
gonna wrap this up um when I have guests
on they get to ask a question of the day
of the audience so these people are very
very old like 25 to 40 or watching and
so and so what question would you like
to ask that demo in the context of where
your worlds at right now you each could
ask one question hobby is there anything
you're curious about of what that may be
that business world things or just that
demo things like what's your gut
probably this is already satellite
questions thought it out you thought you
can go anywhere play some music
huh okay did it maybe does it have to be
a question or no me I don't know you
want for um for like you know statement
of the day yeah you likes thank you
today this is nothing missus a so any
like over I think musically is a
well-rounded app and it's for all ages
and I think that all their age group
should be able to do it too and express
how they want maybe they can use like
songs from their past when they were a
child and bring it back shoulders yeah
bring it back to like the new days show
like oh this is vice have you noticed
some of the older like have you've seen
an older demo starting in the last
couple of songs uh-huh there's some
people that are older and they start
using which I like it because I like
old-school music personally I'm what you
consider vulgar like the lie mm well my
mom is like 37
she was born in like the 80s and 90s
stylist to 90s like DMX yeah biggie and
all that so like I've old old stuff yeah
I've done musically too a lot of old
school songs she loves when I do them
yeah yeah I think it'll be great for
older people to try it and maybe it'll
bring back their childhood a like
memories for like we love yeah memories
thank you
you got a question or stay no based out
of that then will you guys try musically
and try it out and how do you guys think
it will be or how do you like it and
everything self love it thank you guys
so much for having you thank you nothing
but the best
ah let's do this these ladies came all
the way out here to have this amazing
show gave us a lot of insight I Twitter
stock and and let's let you know one of
the things about the show is you know I
want actions I want to help a lot of you
I do see this as a platform that is
going to continue to age up and more
importantly musically is big enough
right now that you have to take the bet
well musically become snapchat and
Instagram my early intuitions are I
think it's a lot a real shot could it
become a Yik yak or a social game sure I
mean that's part of the game but it's
already at a scale and a size right now
that for every one of you
49 year old Don construction worker no
prin not parents all of you need to go
figure out and especially by the way I
alluded to this music much like
photography is not something that comes
very natural to me I already know and I
listen I put out to music I haven't done
anything I haven't lips suck I haven't
done anything yet but I'm desperately
thinking like I've been thinking of like
you know what I'm just gonna make Rick
Ross hustling video like music over my
day-to-day because that's what I'm doing
like I think we all have to challenge
ourselves to figure out our creative
outlet in a platform that's growing and
especially for a lot of you that have
brands that want to sell to 13 to 25
this is a demo that's going to live in
this platform as we head into and the
reason I brought up summer quite a bit
if you look at the historic nature of
social networks enormous growth happens
in that summer when they're all home and
they can produce more and they can talk
more and they're not tied up so I think
we're just on a verge of a very
important three-month period for this
platform and I would take that very very
seriously ladies thank you again good
luck with
turi on your lines lipstick lines and
your nail polish lines India you like
that that was impressive right you keep
asking questions we'll keep answering
them